el huevo está cubierto por una capa de
células llamada Corona radiata el
esperma debe empujar a través de esta
capa para llegar a la capa exterior del
óvulo la zona pelúcida cuando el
espermatozoide llega a la zona peluda se
une a unos receptores especializados de
espermatozoides en la superficie lo que
causa que sus acrosomas liberen enzimas
digestivas lo que permite que los
espermatozoides se introduzcan en la
capa
dentro de la zona pelúcida hay un
espacio estrecho y lleno de líquido
justo afuera de la membrana de la célula
del óvulo el primer espermatozoide en
hacer contacto fertiliza el óvulo